charles robinson tweeted out we're like
two minutes into padded practices
and this this bomb that trey lands
through
already has uh 49er fans thinking
they're going to the super bowl charles
robinson yahoo sports joins the show
do you enjoy these highlights that go
viral for a day in august and get
everybody gassed up
we are we're at the height of optimism
right now pre pre pads is about
it's about as rich as the optimism gets
at this stage every
every guy looks amazing you know you're
you're uh
i i mean that was a good pass but i'm
like yeah
the league's not ready for him
let's flash forward in six months and
it's going to be the narrator voice the
league was ready for trail
i think i think we're gonna see him go
through some lumps
i was out there look he looked i thought
you know he apparently was this
exquisite the day before i got out there
the day i was there i think it was a
little more
normalized he was throwing some stuff
into traffic
um he did hit brandon isaac when i was
there on this 25-yard crossing route
where
i mean it was a it was like an elway
like 25-yard rope just sick
pass the kind that you're like okay
jimmy garoppolo can't do that like i get
that
so um you know you know he looked good
but
i'm i'm out with zach wilson right now
in the in the jets and it's the same
situation where you know
looks good ball gets out of scan quickly
but we won't know anything about
these guys for you know a couple of
months until
i where was everybody talking about
justin herbert being a world beater last
year and then you know the game start
and
next thing i know i got you know teams
that did not have good evals on them
telling me yeah you know i think we
missed on that guy i think he's going to
be
a great player so we got to got to get
him on the field before we start doing
this craziness
charles you mentioned being out there
with the jets and having a look at zach
wilson
who celebrated his 22nd birthday which
is just half as old as tom brady which
is insane
uh i i would not be doing a service to
the man who sits in this chair every day
rich eisen if i didn't ask
for a zack wilson jets update what are
you seeing out there
with the jets um you know like i said i
mean
he he throws a good ball he gets it out
of his hand quickly um
you know he's he's pretty decisive but
again it's
it's still early i think what's going to
be interesting is they're going to have
a lot of
the the line is going to be a lot of
zone schemes and i think
you know makai bectum is unreal
but i don't know if he's a zone left
tackle so i'm curious to kind of see
how that plays out for him you know he's
going to have to be lighter on his feet
and move around and you know
that's if you're talking about zack
wilson you're talking about his left
tackle so
that guy can't afford to miss um this
season so i'm curious to see
you know how he does in their zone
schemes but um
the talent is clearly there he throws
the deep ball it's perfect i mean it's
tight it's
you know he's i get it you you
understand
why they drafted them athleticism but
again
you know we're we're barely into pads
and um
it's gonna take some time and now that
the surrounding roster
um now they've they've improved it i'll
give them that like the roster
definitely the last time i was through
here is 2019
and there's no question in my mind the
roster looks better
i'll tell you what the the elijah moore
kid that they took in the second round
the wide receiver
is a vacuum like if a ball gets near him
he's catching it and which is
you know he's been pretty impressive
just watching him today and
um you know corey davis i think it's
going to be a good a good addition for
them but
uh there's there's going to be some
kinks to work out for them schematically
and you know wilson's going to go
through his lumps but early on
there's no uh not standing out here
going oh man
this looks like this is going to be a
long-term work in progress like
sometimes you get when you
get guys to go in the first round
charles robinson joins the show yahoo
sports senior nfl reporter they got good
snacks out there at tr uh training camp
good snack selection
i don't know they put us up on a balcony
i don't see any snacks up here and i'm
like
i don't know if i don't know if you want
to put a lot of jets reporters up on a
think balcony you're dumping fate you
know i don't know how long you can
cover the jets from a balcony and not
think twice about
give him a fig newton or something some
kind of snack or a bag of peanuts
let's stay in new york let's talk about
the new york giants who are one day into
pads and already have a fight so what's
going on with dan
daniel jones and the giants well don't
fight on top of the quarterback
you know like that's the only i'm i'm
not a
i'm not against camp fights i know some
coaches hate it because
you know i think it's a 50 50
proposition sometimes that you know gets
the juice one and
guys are into it it develops some kind
of a mentality but you know
other half of it is creates animus
sometimes get injured but i've never
heard of people
people get into a brawl on top of the
starting quarterback
who by the way is still not a known
commodity
i still we don't know if daniel jones is
gonna be a good player or not it's
definitely not gonna be a good play to
keep fighting on top
they might not have known he was the
quarterback they might have just thought
he was a kicker
or just a random lineman or somebody
else
it's a bad sign they're like that was a
punter
um i you know it's interesting this is
we're getting that second run of joe
judge and you know some guys are going
to love them some guys aren't going to
like them so much
um i think you know i i i
it's hard to know right now what joe
judge is ultimately going to believe you
know because he
i feel like he is very much i love him
or hate him kind of guy like he's got
that kind of a program
i don't want to bring up belichick but
he is kind of like belichick that way
where you know if you're if you're in
the program you're buying into it you
know he's going to buy into you but if
you're not on the program you're not
listening
you're not buying india look at calvin
benjamin i mean you know they bring the
kid in
the dave gattleman you know invite and
you know or the big gentleman pick up
and they told them lose weight
you know come in you're you're at
whatever i think it's like 260 and
full squad minis they're like you lose
some weight and get in here here's what
we want you to play at and
showed up i think three pounds heavier
and that's the joe judge cut
right there that's like no no we're not
we're not gonna have that we're not
playing this game so
um hopefully they can get ken gallaudet
back on the field you know the hamstring
that that stinks for them that's
definitely a guy they need working with
daniel jones right now but
um i think a lot of this is just going
to rest on to daniel jones development
and let's see what saquon looks like
charles let's stay in the division tj is
already pre-gaming for the super bowl
out here in los angeles because of all
the weapons the dallas cowboys have on
offense
zeke's in the best shape of his career i
know they say that every training camp
but this year it's true
amari cooper gallup cd lamb's gonna have
a big
second year you think tj should slow
down if he wants to make it to super
bowl or should he just start celebrating
now
well let's see if the quarterback can
get through his camp arm first i mean
before we
it's concerning you know that dak
already
had some fatigue on that arm coming in
and you know not a huge surprise i think
some of it was he was loading up a
little bit
and then you know i think it was a
little bit of a workload that
caused the fatigue but i i don't like
that it's been this long
you know you hear a couple of days and
then it stretches into a week and now
i'm starting to wonder how long this
will go but
look zeke i was there zeke looks
fantastic i mean he looks like
his freshman year at ohio state he says
that was when he was last at 2 18. he
looks it
um tyron smith looks unbelievable i mean
they physically
there's a lot to like there but i think
it's you know where are you going to get
the pass rush from how consistent is it
going to be
um the secondary you know is is travon
digs going to be enough to
kind of gel that group there's a lot
defensively a question
and then you know i want to see i want
to see jack on the field
i'll tell you what about cd lamb though
he's uh
when i was there because the mario
cooper's not there um
you know they were playing them outside
which that was a big question like how
much
you know can he be an outside receiver
you look great to me
and i think he's clear in a way he's the
number one receiver in the nfl
and i think amari cooper's number one
and so
you got two number ones gallops great i
mean there's no question offensively
they're stacked it's just uh
let's see how dak responds to you know
continue to put fatigue on that arm and
although he looked completely healthy
his ankle looked
fine to me and he ran around a lot you
know we got to get a couple months into
this to make sure there's nothing like
lingering or nothing's going to get
inflamed or blow up at some point
charles robinson joins the show yahoo
sports senior nfl reporter ben lyons in
for rich on the rich eisen show you may
have created a monster there charles
because tj was just
pumping his fists in the air getting all
hyped up over cd lamb probably gonna
come in tomorrow the cd lamb jersey
so he's he's he's lose his mind over
there so thank you for having us
you know we have to deal with that now
for the rest of the show uh let's uh
let's uh let's stay uh in the division
uh and let's talk a little bit about
some of these rumors we're hearing this
morning about the eagles
possibly making a trade for deshaun
watson
i don't understand it because with
everything happening around deshawn
watson right now i would not want him on
my football team
what is philadelphia thinking with this
i mean it's immense amount of risk and
here's the thing about the philly
the the deal with philly so when teams
started to drop out of that
um march and april you know 49ers
backed away um the the panthers backed
away the jets backed away
what was interesting now all those
franchises when they're backing away
they all said the same thing
watch philly they all believe philly was
going to be the one that was going to
make the big run at him
um and and frankly once carolina fell
out i thought carolina was really the
one
what carolina was gonna offer three
first three thirds i mean they were
gonna make a big offer
you know before all this stuff broke
loose with sean and
um so the philly thing's been out there
for a while but
i think the question that i have and you
know i've talked to a number of gm's
who you know either were involved with
this are still involved with this
and the one thing that i think is pretty
consistent is everybody wants to manage
the risk
so the the what i mean by that is i had
one gm who
who i think definitely has some interest
said
okay i need some pick protection like if
we're going to do this
i don't know what's going to happen five
minutes after i trade for the guy he's
like that's you know i'm worried about
everything but i'm definitely worried
about what i don't know yet
and so his thought process
was if he gets suspended half a season i
want one of my first to turn into a
second round pick if he gets suspended
for a full season
or gets indicted and you know faces
felony charges i want
two of my first turning into second
round picks like they just want
protection
in the long term for the packages they
have to give up
i i have no idea where you know what
philly's thinking in terms of
you know the protections i don't know i
have not heard that is that far along
frankly from what was what i saw today
out on twitter um
and i think a big part of that is and i
think you know
uh pro football talks mike florio
touched on this the harris county
prosecutor's got to decide
if he's going to advance um some of this
information to a grand jury
and if they see the grand jury that's a
whole different
i mean i i can't see nfl any nfl team
trading for him because they got to sit
there and
say is this guy getting indicted on
felony and
if he gets indicted on felonies you know
the league's going to step in
i think the league's just waiting to see
what the you know
houston police department and the harris
county prosecutor ultimately decided to
do with it so
this idea is about to be dealt i'm just
i don't know man i tend to believe from
the legal standpoint and i'm not even
talking about the civil suits i'm
talking about the criminal stuff
um i think teams are still really
worried about that and and what might
happen
after a trade i would be shocked to be
honest to see him back on a football
field
this season charles appreciate you
taking some time man thanks for checking
in i hope you get some good snacks out
there at jet's practice they got to feed
you guys i'm looking right now i just
see like gatorade and
that's pretty much it so but uh you know
what keep
keep watching cd lambs you're a great
player this year i'm glad i had you guys
up on that good stuff man thanks for
taking some time all right take care
charles robinson joining the show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here